do you find multi-modal learning
interesting we've been talking about
visual language like combining those
together maybe audio all those kinds of
things there's a lot of things that i
find interesting in the short term but
are not
addressing the important problems that i
think are really kind of the big
challenges so i think you know things
like multitask learning continual
learning
uh you know
adversarial issues i mean those have you
know great practical interests in the
relatively short term
uh possibly but i don't think they're
fundamental you know active learning
even to some extent reinforcement
learning i think
those things will
become either obsolete or
or useless or easy
once we figured out how to do
self-supervised representation learning
or or learning predictable models
and so i think that's what you know
the entire community should be focusing
on uh at least people are interested in
sort of fundamental questions or you
know really kind of pushing the envelope
of ai towards the next the next stage
but of course there's like a huge amount
of you know very interesting work to do
in sort of practical questions that have
you know short-term impact well you know
it's it's difficult to talk about the
temporal scale because
all of human civilization will
eventually be destroyed because the the
the sun will die out and even if elon
musk is successful multi-planetary
colonization across the galaxy uh
eventually
the entirety of it would just become
giant black holes and uh
that's gonna take a while though
so but but what i'm saying is then that
logic can be used to say it's all
meaningless
i'm saying all that to say that
multitask learning
[Music]
might be
your song you're calling it practical or
pragmatic or whatever
that might be the thing that achieves
something very akin to intelligence
while we're trying to solve the more
uh general problem of self-supervised
learning and background knowledge so the
reason i bring that up maybe one
way to ask that question i've been very
impressed by what tesla auto poly team
is doing i don't know if you got any
chance to glance at this particular one
example of
multi-task learning where they're
literally taking the problem
like i don't know charles darwin starts
studying animals they're studying
the problem of driving and asking okay
what are all the things you have to
perceive
and
the way they're solving it is one
there's an ontology where you're
bringing that to the table so you're
formulating a bunch of different tasks
it's like over a hundred tasks or
something like that then they're
involved in driving and then they're
deploying it and then getting data back
from people that run into trouble and
they're trying to figure out do we add
tasks do we like we focus on each
individual task separately sure in fact
half so the i would say i would classify
andre kapathy's talk in two ways so one
was about doors
and the other one about how much
imagenet sucks
he kept going
back and forth on those two topics which
imagine that sucks meaning you can't
just use a single benchmark
there's so like you you have to have
like a a giant suite of benchmarks to
understand how well your your system
actually i agree with him i mean he's uh
he's a very sensible guy um
now
okay it's it's very clear that if you're
faced with a an engineering problem that
you need to solve in a relatively short
time particularly if you have it almost
breathing down your neck
you're gonna have to take shortcuts
right you you you might think about the
the fact that the
the the right thing to do in the
long-term solution involves you know
some fancy self-supervisioning but you
have
you know you know almost reading it on
your neck uh and you know this involves
uh you know human lives and so you you
have to
basically just do the systematic uh
engineering and you know
uh
fine tuning and refinements and trial
and error and and all that stuff um
there's nothing wrong with that that's
that's called engineering that's called
you know uh
putting technology out uh in the
in the world um and and you have to kind
of ironclad it before before you do this
you know
um uh
so much for you know grand grand ideas
and principles
um
but you know i'm placing myself sort of
you know some
you know upstream of this you know quite
a bit of stream of this your plato think
about platonic forms you're you're not
platonic because eventually
i want that stuff to get used but uh
it's okay if it takes
five or ten years for the community to
realize this is the right thing to do
i've done this before it's been the case
before that you know i've made that that
case i mean if you look back in the
mid-2000s for example and you ask
yourself the question okay i want to
recognize cars or faces or whatever
you know i can use convolutional net so
i can use a more conventional
uh kind of computer vision techniques
you know using uh interest point
detectors or sift density features and
you know sticking an svm on top at that
time the data sets were so small that
those
methods that used more hand engineering
worked better than combines there was
just not enough data for comnets and
contests were a little a little slow
with the kind of hardware that was
available at the time
and there was a c change when uh
basically when you know
data sets became bigger and and gpus
became available that that's what
you know those
two of the main factors that basically
made people change their change their
mind
and you can
you can look at the history of
like all sub-branches of ai or pattern
recognition
and there's a similar trajectory
followed by techniques where people
start by you know engineering the hell
out of it
you know
be it
optical character recognition
speech recognition
computer vision like image recognition
in general uh natural language
understanding like you know translation
things like that right you start to
engineer the hell out of it
um you start to acquire all knowledge
the prior knowledge you know about image
formation about you know the shape of
characters about you know
morphological operations about like
feature extraction fourier transforms
you know venice moments you know
whatever right people have come up with
thousands of ways of representing images
so that they could be easily uh
classified afterwards same for speech
recognition right there is
you know two decades for people to
figure out a good front end uh to
pre-process uh
a speech signal so that you know the
information about what is being said is
preserved but most of the information
about the identity of the speaker is
gone um
you know kestrel coefficients or
whatever right um and same for for text
right uh you do need entity recognition
and you parse and you
you you do tagging of
of of the parts of speech and you know
you do this sort of tree representation
of clauses and all that stuff right
before you can do anything
um
so
that's how it starts right just engineer
the hell out of it and then you start
having data
and maybe you have more powerful
computers maybe you know something about
statistical learning so you start using
machine learning and it's usually a
small sliver on top of your kind of
handcrafted system where you know you
extract features by hand okay and now
you know nowadays the standard way of
doing this is that you train the entire
thing end-to-end with the deep learning
system and it learns its own features
and
and you know speech recognition systems
nowadays
ocr systems are completely end-to-end
it's
you know it's some giant neural net that
takes raw waveforms
and produces a sequence of characters
coming out and it's just a huge neural
net right there's no
you know markov model there's no
language model that is explicit other
than you know something that's ingrained
in the in the sort of neural language
model if you want same for translation
same for all kinds of stuff so you see
this
continuous evolution
from
you know less and less handcrafting and
more and more learning
um
and uh i i think uh
i mean it's true in biology as well
so i mean
we might disagree about this maybe not
uh in this one little piece at the end
you mentioned active learning
it feels like active learning which is
the selection of data and also the
interactivity needs to be part of this
giant neural network you cannot just be
an observer to do self-supervised
learning you have to well
i don't self supervise learning is just
a word but i would whatever this giant
stack of a neural network that's
automatically learning it feels my
intuition is
that
you have to have a system whether it's a
physical robot or a digital robot that's
interacting with the world and doing so
in a flawed way and improving over time
in order to to form the self-supervised
learning
well you can't just give it a giant sea
of data okay i agree and i disagree okay
i agree in the sense that i think
i agree i agree in two ways the first
the first way i agree is that if you
want uh
and you certainly need a causal model of
the world that allows you to predict the
consequences of your actions
to train that model you need to take
actions right you need to be able to act
in a world and see the effect
for you to be to learn causal models of
the world well so that's not that's not
obvious because you can observe others
you can observe others and you can infer
that they're similar to you and then you
can learn from that yeah but then you
have to kind of hardwire that part right
you know mirror neurons and all that
stuff right so um and it's not clear to
me how you would do this in a machine so
um
so i think the the action part would be
necessary for having causal models of
the world
the second reason it may be
necessary or at least more efficient is
that
uh active learning basically you know
goes for the jiggler of what you're what
you don't know right
is this you know obvious areas of
uncertainty
uh about your your world and about the
how the world behaves
and
you can resolve this uncertainty by
systematic exploration of that part that
you don't you don't know and if you know
that you don't know then you know it
makes you curious you kind of look into
situations that
and uh you know across the animal uh
world
different species are different levels
of curiosity right
depending on how they're built right so
you know cats and rats are incredibly
curious uh dogs know so much i mean less
yeah so it could be useful to have that
kind of curiosity so it'd be useful but
curiosity just makes the process faster
it doesn't make the process exist
the
so what process what learning process
is it that
active learning makes more efficient
and i'm asking that first question uh
you know
you know we haven't answered that
question yet so you know i worry about
active learning once this question is so
it's the more fundamental question to
ask
and if active learning or
interaction
increases the efficiency of the learning
see sometimes
it becomes very different if the
increase is several orders of magnitude
right like that's true
but fundamentally it's still the same
thing and building up the intuition
about how to
in a self-supervised way to construct
background models efficient or
inefficient
is um
is the core problem
you